so guess we'll start on time so the
first stop today is the best option PETA
from target University will tell us
about the removal them of this trinomial
bounds ok so good morning everybody and
thanks for the organizers for inviting
me here it's always a pleasure to be
here and they will talk about a joint
work with my a PhD student Leo inch
Bellino ok so the title of the talk is
removal hemos with polynomial bounds so
I will start with some background and
where are these problems coming from so
I think one of the most natural problems
the abstract problem to study about
graphs or any other automatically object
is the relation between its global
properties and its local properties ok
we would like to ask a question suppose
the graph doesn't satisfy poverty can we
found can we find a local proof of this
fact ok so we start by defining what it
means for a glove to be far from satisfy
the property of course if the graph is
doesn't satisfy the poverty just because
of a single edge then we have no chance
of finding a small proof of this fact so
if we once we define it a distance then
we're we're really in good shape so we
say that the graph on n vertices is
epsilon files of satisfying a fixed 4
30p if we need to change to add and or
delete at least epsilon n square edges
to make the graph satisfy the property
ok so if you look at the adjacency
matrix of the graph you need to modify
an OPS an epsilon fraction of its
entries in order to get a graph that
satisfies the poverty ok and so what is
the notion of local versus global that
we will study here so we will say that
they have edited glass poverty so what
is a property is an editor if it is
closed under removal of vertices so if
you if we want to study properties for
which a small subset of vertices is the
doesn't satisfy the property is the
witness to the fact that the entire
graph doesn't satisfy the property then
basically we're talking about the ready
Telegraph property right like being
triangle free if we find the triangle in
a graph it's a proof that the entire
graph is not triangle free oh if its
capability if we find a sub graph that
is
okay callable then we know that the
entire graph is not clay callable okay
now so we have a some hella de telegraaf
property p and we will say that it is
testable and the reason for calling it
testable and not something else would be
clear in the next slide we said it is
testable if for every graph G if jeez
epsilon file from satisfying the
property according to this notion then
if will then with probability at least
two-thirds if will sample a constant
number of vertices this constant is
determined by this function f that might
depend on the property p but it depends
only on epsilon and not on that on end
the number of vertices so if will sample
this many vertices then we probability
it leads two thirds with the sub graph
spent by these vertices will not satisfy
the property okay so you can ask why my
book making two thirds and not see all
right you can say just we were just in
be interested in just one sub graph
doesn't satisfy the property the reason
for these two thirds is that in almost
all K in old all cases when once we can
prove that its larger than zero we can
immediately prove that its larger than
two-thirds and because it will have some
nice algorithmic application that are we
mentioned in the next slide okay so
unfortunately in many cases when even
when we can show that the graph property
is testable the this function f of
epsilon is some horrendous tower type
function so it makes sense to us to even
ask for more and ask say that the glass
properties easily testable if this
function is polynomially in 1 over
epsilon okay okay so easily so
connectivity is not hereditary right
according to definition
so connectivity is because you can
always make a linear number of
modifications to make a glove connector
then this is can it's not interesting in
this okay so some well-known results
that followed into this framework so a
the famous removal amour fou Johnson
already states that if o'clock is
epsilon file from being triangle free
then it contains n cubed over f of
epsilon copies of K 3 okay so if you
need to modify an epsilon fraction of
the edges of the graph to make the graph
triangle free then you can take a
positive fraction of all possible
triangles of the graph and it's easy to
see that is there's the equivalent to
saying that k 3 freeness being triangle
free is testable okay now if i'll get
back to this definition then notice that
of course for the property of being
triangle free we know that if the graph
is foul for Mickey triangle feed
contains at least one triangle in that
sense having the zero he'll doesn't make
any sense right we know that it will
contain one triangle that the main I the
main problem is how to show that they
contain lots of triangles ok but observe
that if I take a reddit early property
for which the number of forbidden
subgraphs is infinite then it's not
clear up really why should there even be
one such off right and perhaps the most
natural question to ask is about the
property of being k callable so actually
elvish asked not in this words but yes
is it true that if a graph is epsilon
far from being horrible then it contains
a sub graph on a constant number of
vertices that is not high caliber ok so
we have this small proof of the non k
call ability of the graph and this was
proved by a little and you can actually
what they proved is not only that one
such sub graph existed but if you simple
enough vertices then with probability at
least two-thirds this sub graph will not
be cake horrible okay so some simple
observation is that which is just a
generalization of the equivalence the
tighthead here is that proving a removal
emma in this language meaning that
showing that if a graph is far from
satisfying the property then it contains
many copies of the forbidden sidewalks
is just equivalent to show in the
detestable
okay it's an easy observation and
another even simple observation that the
family of already telegraphed properties
is just equivalent to the family of if
I'll take all possible families of graph
H and I look at the properties of being
induced h flick right because let's for
example being k callable is just
equivalent to saying that you don't
contain a non k callable subbed off ok
ok so now why do we call these
properties testable so as I mentioned
here that these problems were implicitly
started already in the 70s and the 80s
but the the main boosts to this area
came from a famous paper by Goethe
corazon want from 20 years ago and so
what they started the systematic study
of this of this phenomena and and a very
interesting thing which is motivates our
word here is the following is that
though the proof of OSHA seminary of the
triangular removal emma relies on the
reg reality level so the function he
life of epsilon is done is some towel
type function of epsilon and still the
best known bout is also this tower type
function now the original proof of ladle
and you could also use the regularity
lemma and so here the bound was also at
a low type function of epsilon but
remarkably what they bought gold record
on 71 managed to do is to probably
because they weren't aware of this of
this result is that is that managed to
prove this without using the regularity
remind us getting a polynomial bound ok
em ok so about ten years ago I proved
together with the with Naga alone is it
actually every a great Italian opera is
testable okay so for every a relatively
property if a glove is epsilon far from
satisfied with property it has a small
proof of this or the fact that the glove
doesn't satisfy the property moreover
actually we can find this witness very
easy ok ok i forgot to mention something
ok so what is the algorithmic
application here that we have of this
notion is that suppose we want to
distinguish between a graph that satisfy
that italy property from a graph that is
file epsilon falcom satisfying the
property for example cake or ability we
know that it's epsilon it's NP hard to
distinguish myntra graph that is three
collarbone and not recallable but
suppose we only want to pay to solve the
diplomas problem well we know that the
graph is either k callable or epsilon
far from being a callable so the notion
of the stability means that we can
actually solve this problem in constant
time well this constant that just
depends on this function f of epsilon we
sample f of X you don vertices and we
look at the sub graph and maker of
course this is a randomized algorithm
with only distinguishes between these
two cases with high probability okay so
any questions up to now so this is an
implication about the key randomization
of this algorithms like if something is
life testable what do we know about the
randomizing them having deterministic
kind of test so it's given to cart 0
didn't know anything for me still which
forward well look the promises they
still the promised problem but I want to
deterministic algorithm you should go
over all subjects yes what do you belong
to the strength is almost a year it'll
be Polly some type of excellent
go just over all subsets then you're
going to do to find one okay so am again
so this so we know that every reddit
early property is actually a testable
and the proof unfortunately uses the
regularity lemma so we get actually even
worse than tau what I bounds its
waterside bounds or even worse and what
we can and what we also managed to prove
is that actually in some generate cases
and I am that this bount are unavoidable
if you'll give me any function of
epsilon I can cook up a reddit Eric
property for which the removal emma has
to be the bounds on the removal mi have
to be to grow at least as fast as this
as this function even if it's a non
recursive function okay but of course
it's not a natural graph property that
witnesses this fact so what is the
natural question a natural question is
for which a little poverty can we get
polynomial bounds meaning for which our
editor a poet can we show that they are
actually easily testable and for as I've
said before for some very natural
properties like being cake or but we
know that the bound is actually
polynomial in epsilon in one of our EPS
ago ok so again so they I'm just
repeating the definition of what it
means to be easily testable and perhaps
they're the more interesting
philosophical question if you want here
is that for which poverty's can we prove
the removal Emma so we know that we can
prove a removal Emma for every area
literally property by using the
regularity lemma which is like solving a
nuclear bomb on it okay but you're
interesting to know whether for which
properties can we do this in a more
defined way okay and perhaps the
ultimate goal is to show that for every
related early property we can prove a
removal Emma without the regularity
lemma for example for perhaps the most
basically instance is just before the
property of being triangle free for
which we don't know how to pull this
without a certain version of the
regularity lemma okay and so again so
the question is a way by gold rock in
about ten years ago and by a Naga and
Jacob a couple of years ago and another
conjecture of Naga was that at least for
a very structured family of hereditary
these which are called semi ojeleye
class properties for these properties we
should be able to prove a polynomial
bound okay so i'll define these this
family of properties precisely in in a
few slides but for for now you can
imagine that these are the properties
for example of being a an interval graph
or the intersection graph of spheres in
our 40 and these types of properties
okay so what was known before so a knock
approved in there in 2002 the topology
of being aged free so this is not being
induced h3 being h3 that it is easily
testable meaning that it has a removal
Emma with a polynomial bound if and only
the graph is bipartite okay so for
example for k1 for the bipartite graph
on 200 vertices the Bounty's polynomial
but for triangle it's not polynomial and
a a couple of years later we proved the
similar results for the Pope for the
property of being induced age Phylly so
in this case we proved so for example
okay so proving a removal Emma for
single edges is kind of easy proving an
aluminum a removal Emma for a path of
length 3 this is this is an exercise and
we proved it for every other graph on at
least five vertices it's always hard so
as AK as opposed to the case of being
aged Phylly there are only finitely many
graphs for which there is appalling
there is a four graphs H for which there
is a polynomial bound so the two graphs
that remain open where the cycle of
length 4 and the path of length for now
the path of length 4 was resolved a
couple of years ago by a Naga and Jacob
and this is a theory this is no longer
an exercise they proved that actually
the reduced p for furnace is easily
testable and this relies on the indica
and the structural characterization of p
for free graphs that there are koloff's
meaning that you can generate all these
graphs by taking a disjoint union of two
p43 gloves or taking a union and a
complete bipartite graph between them
okay
okay so so sorry 0 so c4 is still open
and so what are the new results okay so
our first result okay so it says that so
for now we're only talking about a
hereditary properties remember that we
are thinking about letting properties in
terms of their family of forbidden sub
coughs okay and for not for the time
being I will only talk about hereditary
properties for which the familiar
forbidden got sub graph is finite okay
so suppose we have a finite family of
graph H and this family contains a
bipartite graph so you know what is a
bipod got a call bipartite graph a co
bipartite graph is a is a graph where
you can partition it into two clicks as
opposed to independent set and the split
cough a split graph is where when you
can partition the graph into two sets
one of them is an independent set and
the other one is it is a complete graph
okay so if your family contains one of
these one guy like this one guy like
this and one then the family then the
property of being h3 induced actually is
easily testable meaning you can prove
the move ulema for this family with a
polynomial bound okay so some immediate
color is is that the property of being
induced p33 this is the result in my
paper with Noga then it's easy because
you can convince yourself very easily
that the path of length on two edges is
both a bipartite echo bipartite and
split graph and also the result of naga
and jacob about the path of length 4
again because this p for itself is a
bipartite go by about that in a split
graph and also the property of being h3
is opposed for by contact age again it's
it's a simple observation and some I
think these are these were no no that
being a line graph and being a threshold
graph are also easily testable because
they are characterized by finite a
number for bit inside induced sub graph
then they contain these three guys okay
so remember that the Holy the perhaps
the the ultimate goal would be to find a
precise characterization of when can we
obtain a removal em up with the
polynomial bound
and perhaps an easier question would be
just to get such a characterization for
finite families ok so the it's a natural
to ask is it too is it an if and only if
condition this is a nice combinatorial
condition unfortunately it turns out
that it is that it's not so for example
if we look at the family that contains
the cycle of length for the compliment
of a cycle of length 4 and the 5 cycle
then this the property of being free of
these guys is easy simply because it
turns out that this is this big not
containing any of these guys is just
equivalent to being a split cloth ok so
of course this family does it contain
split laughs and it's not hard to show
that the property of being a split graph
is easily testable it follows from the
result of gold or 12 us ignored ok so
this is sufficient but not a necessary
condition ok so what about the necessary
condition so what we show is that again
so we have a finite family and what we
show is that if it's if test if removal
if there is an efficient removal Emma
for being aged free then you must
contain a bipartite eneko bipartite ok
so we know that these three guys are
sufficient and we know that having two
of them is also necessary and again it's
easy to derive from this sufficient
necessary condition also the result of
Naga about about the hardness of H
freeness for non bipartite H and about
the hardness of almost every age for
induced faithfulness this is was my
result with Naga okay and again it turns
out that this necessary condition is not
sufficient this time it's not such a
simple observation so this is a theorem
that there is about by pal bipartite f1
and a co-pilot at f2 such the testing
induced earthliness is out focus for
example we can take f1 the bipartite
graph to be the eighth cycle and the co
bipartite graph to be a the complement
of a matching of size eight ok
one induce to non induced in the corona
it is easy to see what the first corolla
d then how do you remove the induced
thing to get no there isn't it's easy
okay so now we are moving to a infinite
families of graphs so theory one says
that if we have a finite family of
graphs and it contains a bipartite echo
by file type LS plate-glass then we have
an efficient removal Emma or it's easily
testable and now we can say it's natural
to ask is it is it is it true that this
is also true for an infinite infinite
family of forbidden sub graphs and
perhaps an even nicer a way to describe
this this possibility is to observe that
satisfying this condition meaning that
if you have a family of glass that
contain a pipe out at a cobalt ight and
split graph then the poverty of being
free of this family is it implies that
your poverty has bounded vc-dimension
meaning that the adjacency matrix of
every graph that satisfies this property
has pounded VC dimension so this
possibility it can just be stated as
easy to that every glass property with
bounded VC dimension has an efficient
removal Emma okay it turns out that the
answer is no okay so there is an
infinite family of course it cannot be
finite because stealing one says that
when the family is finite then there is
an efficient removal Emma there is an
infinite family of gloves that contains
these three guys but still there is no
efficient removal emma for this family
okay but just like in the case so that i
mentioned before with my paper with no
guy about this impossibility result for
a redditor report is this this family
again is not a very natural it's not a
natural graph property we just cook it
for the sake of this argument so it's
it's natural again to us whether de
quite the answer to this question is
positive for natural poverty editora
properties and there is a very natural
family of properties with bounded VC
dimension and it's the family of semi
algebra across properties okay so what
are semi-autobiographical parties so
it's every algebraic poverty
p is given by a fixed number of
polynomials f1 up to FD in 2k variables
well k so k is fixed and t is fixed and
a boolean function 012 the t20 one okay
and we will say and with which graph
satisfy this property we say that the
glove satisfy the property if we can
assign every vertex of the graph a
vector in R K okay such that how do you
test whether these two vertices x and y
should be adjacent in the graph you just
plug x and y to these t polynomials and
check whether they are non-negative and
then you take all these boolean values
and then you plug them into the boolean
function side and you share and you
check whether it's 10 0 and this tells
you whether there should be an edge or
not okay so it's like you have a
certificate for the fact that the graph
satisfy the property or not okay so
many of the most well-known what were
these studies popper these out semi and
you buy for example being the most basic
example general families there's just
the intersection graph of semi and
Jabbar set so interval graphs unit
gloves a graph intersection of segments
in the plane circular our graphs you can
you can continue this list okay so and
the Nagas conjecture that indeed every
property of this type has an efficient
removal Emma or equivalently is easily
testable and what we can show is that
the answer is indeed true that this is
the case
okay and there so we worked a lot about
on this problem and it seems like when
you think about it seems like the
solution would have to be some like
hardcore g by an argument and
surprisingly there is almost nothing I
mean it's almost everything is almost
purely combinatorial in the entire proof
and the proof actually follows from a
more general convenience combinatorial
sufficient condition that guarantees
that the property has an efficient
removal Emma so let me just describe
this condition so bear with me so let F
be a graph and let F be a function from
the vertex set of the graph 201 now what
is an F blow up ok so for those who are
not familiar so there is a very natural
thing we do it graphs it and it's to
blow them up so what is a blow up of a
graph so if this is a the four cycle so
a blow-up it we get by replacing every
vertex of the graph by an independent
set and every edge replacing it by
complete bipartite graph and every non
edge by nothing ok so if we'll take a
blow up then we'll get four independent
sets and for complete bipartite graphs
and these two guys there is nothing
between them ok so what is an F blow up
so an F and again we're putting
independent sets in set of vertices so
when F blow up is that is a function
from the vertex of the graph 201 what
this function tells us is whether to
turn a vertex into an independent set of
a click so if F of V is 0 then this
blown-up vertex will become an
independent set and if F of V is 1 then
it will become a click ok so this is an
F blow up so we have a graph F and the
function f ok and we say that a family
of gloves a a family of gloves age has
the blower probability if every graph
that is induced H free okay so every
graph that satisfies the property of
being aged for
has a function f such that every f blow
up of this graph is induced rage free
okay so for example if my poverty is
being cake horrible then how can I take
every graph that is cake horrible and
blow it up in order to get still AK
collar Bell graph what will be the
function f zero right because I will
just replace any vertex with an
independent set right so again so a
relatively property has the blow up or
has the blood property if every graph
that satisfies the property has a
function has a consistent way of blowing
it up in such a way that we will get a
new graph that satisfies the property
I'm i hope i'm not mistaken but for
example the property of being c4 then it
will you will replace if a graph is c4
flee in do you see for free then if you
blow it up and replace every vertex by
click then the new glove will still be
in DC for free I hope this is okay
anyway so this is the definition ok so
again so we want to know that every if
every graph that satisfies the property
there is a consistent way of blowing it
up ok now the theorem says that for
every family of gloves H finite or
infinite if it satisfies the sufficient
condition we have for finite families
age and in an in addition it has the
blower property then it has an efficient
removal Emma ok so we know that the
first item is not sufficient by its own
okay it's efficient for for finite
families for infinite families if we
have if we add this again you will
convene at oriole condition of having
the blower property then we can get a
removal Emma with a polynomial bound
okay now the nice thing is that an
addition le a little bit tricky in the
sense that it took us a while to to
figure it out one line proof then gives
the the fact that every semi algebraic
of properties is easily testable okay
em so i will say a few words about the
poof so can so so if you may jump just
trying to visualize so if you say that
something is not easily testable to show
it it means that you need to come up
this like a big crowd and some super
polynomial in one of epsilon function
stop sub ok sub polynomial supercab kind
of neat things such as every subset
satisfies this property but globally it
doesn't satisfy this property right for
example triangles you need to find a
graph that is far from being triangle
free but still it contains relatively
few triangles less than Paulie epsilon n
cubed triangles nice and this is I guess
no right for triangles it is not ok it
is not because it's a special case of
this theorem of Naga about being aged
flea is it i'm just curious is it
because i haven't seen it is it easy to
show those examples are complicated and
like like it's not if you don't know
anything then it's not easy I mean it
uses a construction i will say a few
words it uses balance construction of a
subset of vertices of subset of the
first n integers without a three total
magnetic progression takes this and
construct a graph like Kylie porque
legal of using this so I don't think it
it qualifies as a simple and in terms of
gaps of Safari terms that easily
testable not easily testable surgeon
simulator so paranoid with one of
excellence nice but then you said the
upper bounds you know that you get there
like the stars of our web so there are a
lot of functions in between are there
not interesting like like to do the one
web so no this is it is event how
natural you want the property to be okay
as I said if you don't care about
unnatural properties then for any
function you will give me even a non
recursive function I can cook up a
property for which the removal Emma
needs to be at least I I cannot show
that it's exactly this function but at
least this function okay for example for
triangle freeness unfortunately the best
upper bound is still a tower of now its
local ethnic in 1 over epsilon
polynomial but the low
just barely super polynomial it's
epsilon to the log 1 over epsilon so
there is a huge gap between the Sun in
general is it do you know some but
somewhere where you know the tower one
of a person's need for example some
property you know where you need but
it's not a natural property is it okay I
mean if i'll show you the example you
say that i'm cheating ok m ok so so the
first theorem was about again for about
finite families h and we had three
forbidden sub of one bipartite 1 hobe
about I'd one split glove and we want to
say that once we have the family
contains these three guys then it's then
the family has an efficient removal Emma
so the first step in the proof is the
following lemma but says the following
the suppose we have these three guys f1
a bipartite graph F to probe about at f3
split cloth then there is a bipartite
graph be on to vertex X X and Y such as
the following holds no matter how what
graph you will place into X and what
glass you will place into why you're
guaranteed to get in the new graph
either an induced copy of f1 or f2 or f3
ok and this is a you just take a random
a big London bipartite graph and use
lunzie steering we'd say it's a nice
exercise once you do it ok so again so
the idea here is that we have a
bipartite graph such that no matter what
happens inside its to vertex sets you're
guaranteed to get either f1 f2 or f3 ok
okay so this is the feeling we're trying
to prove so we need to pull that if G is
epsilon file form a new stage free then
it contains many copies of some H in H
you can think of the case that h1 then
just 11 Gogh okay ah okay perhaps it's
not a good idea since we have three guys
here unless they're all the same
nevermind okay so we need to find many
copies of some graph H in our family so
the first step is that we may assume
that G contains less than poly epsilon n
to the number of vertices of be induced
bipartite copies of B so what is an
induced bipartite copy it means to
vertex sets such that the bipartite
between them is exactly the bipartite
graph B and we don't care what happens
inside the vault exits why don't we care
about what happens inside the vertex set
because of this property of be that no
matter what happens inside these two
vertex s we've know that it contains
either the f1 or f2 or f3 ok so once we
have this assumption we can use a lemma
of a lan feature a new man which says
the following it says that for every
bipartite graph B if a graph G contains
less than poly epsilon n to the 2m
induced by partek copies of be ok just
like we are we may assume here then we
can find an almost homogeneous partition
of V into poorly one over epsilon many
parts so what do I mean by that so
remember they need the regularity ok I
didn't mention the regularity lemma but
it was mentioned before so the
regularity lemma guarantees that you can
partition every graph into a bounded
number of vertex sets such that
bipartite graph between them behave like
random graphs ok but the problem is that
this constant f of epsilon is at our
type function of epsilon right so here
we can partition the graph only into
poly one over epsilon parts and the
bipartite between them even the
situation isn't is even much better than
the regularity lemma because we know
that all of these bipartite graph there
they almost all of them but let's
suppose the seats for all of them
the density between them is either
almost zero or almost one and of course
a bipartite graph with density almost
zero almost one is in particular epsilon
leg around for an appropriate epsilon
but again so this is a much better
situation we're in a much better
situation than we are with the with the
regularity lemma okay m okay so i will
not continue to talk about for now for
the time being about this book because i
will mention well I can get this poof in
the course of proving the mojet the
result about semi algebraic properties
that none of them strictly implies the
other one but the proof of the semi
algebraic properties is this is how them
ok so let me now start from the
beginning about the about proving that
every semi Ajay by glass property is
easily testable ok so for the first step
we want to do something similar to what
i had just in the previous slide ok so
before so we have the following claims
that for a cellular gibault portal
portal DB there is a bipartite be such
that every glove satisfying p does not
contain any deuced bipartite copy of p
ok so what is this glove so this follows
from the fact that a semi algebraic
properties graph properties have bounded
VC dimension which itself follows from a
woven still among the number of sign
patterns of polynomials and because but
because these semi algebraic properties
have bounded VC dimension it it means
that they don't contain a copy of the if
we take this the bipartite graph which
is d by 2 to the D and contains all the
all the 0 1 vectors of length deep ok so
for some fixed deed that depends on the
poverty we don't have any copy of this
bipartite graph as an induced bipartite
graph meaning to vertex sets such
between them we have exactly this
bipartite graph ok ok so let me rephrase
what fuel in five mins it means that if
a graph is epsilon file from satisfying
some semi algebraic portal property P
then we want to show that with high
probability a sample of only poly one
over epsilon many vertices
doesn't satisfy the property okay and as
before as in the case of the of the
theorem about finite families we may
assume that G contains less than poly
epsilon n to the number of vertices of
be well bead is is this bipartite graph
right because if we have this many
copies than we are done ok so again we
can use the allen fisher human lemma and
get an almost homogeneous partition of
the vertex sets into poly one over
epsilon many parts p 1 up to PR ok ok so
what do we do we do now ok so that
so this is the partition ok so we have
these vertex sets and we know that
between them we don't know anything
what's going on inside this vertex sets
we know the bit between them all of the
bipartite graphs are either almost empty
or almost complete okay so what is the
natural thing to do is to say that if a
by particle is almost empty we will just
make it empty if it's almost complete
we'll make it complete right okay so
let's do it so we change the we change G
we change the glass according to the
partition if the density between pinp j
is less than Delta we just delete all
the edges between them if it's almost
one we add all the edges between them ok
so we make relatively few modifications
of the graph so we knew it we assume the
gloves falcom satisfy the property we
know that the graph has a copy of one of
the forbidden subgraphs ok what's the
problem now we would like now like to
show to say that ok so since the cincy i
will suppose our forbidden graph is a c4
ok so if the see four seats here like
this
then we are then we are done right
because we know that what does it mean
that there is that we have a c4 here it
means that the density between these two
guys in the modified graph is now one
but it's one only because it was
originally almost one right and the same
here and the same here in the same heel
and the fact that we don't have an edge
here means that originally the density
was almost zero and the density here was
almost zero right so now we fell if
simply find sample four vertices one
from each of these vertex sets then with
high probability i'll get an indie a
copy of c4 okay but of course i might
not be so lucky right because perhaps my
cycle of length 4 will be have two
vertices heal and two vertices here and
remember that i don't have any control
on what happens inside the vault exits
right okay so why we need another extra
step that was done in almost in all
proof set of variants of the of the of
the induced removal emma which is to
first assume that that we of course we
can assume that each of these vertex set
contains few copies of our forbidden sub
graphs because if they contain mainly
then we'll be done now there is ok so we
using standard tools we can show that
using this assumption we can find a
subset of hpi let's call it Q I which is
almost homogeneous meaning that it's all
either and almost independent set or
almost click ok and now the natural
thing to do is to say okay if this
subset Qi that we found was almost a
click then let's tell p I the entirety I
into an genuine click and if it was
almost independent set let's turn it
into it through entire PR into
independent set and now what I've said
he'll this resolves this problem okay
but his resolve this problem only if you
have a finite number of forbidden sub
graphs because these two subsets this
subject Qi they're not really
independent set so click the only almost
independent almost clicks okay and for
cellulite properties for the property of
being an interval graph there is an
infinite familiar forbidden sub coughs
right so even if we know that after
these modifications the glove doesn't
satisfy the property so there is some
well here there is a graph that doesn't
satisfy the property but how large is it
perhaps it's of sizes who then of course
we know that it's not of size that
depends on we have a small one because
we know that every a reddit le
properties is testable but but it only
guarantee is a subgraph of size of a
normal size right we would want to know
that there is a small sub cough that
doesn't satisfy the property here and
this is the situation where it seems
like some algebraic tools will allow you
to argue why there should be a small sub
graph that doesn't satisfy the property
and after spending a lot of time we
realized this isn't the not the right
way to do it so now I want to show to a
to describe another approach which got
which allows us to pick just one vertex
from each of these clusters ok so we
don't we don't need to know anything
about what happens in these clusters ok
ok so remember so we land in this
situation where we have a partition we
know that the bipartite graph between
this vertex sets are either almost empty
or almost complete and we want to show
that that to find a many copies of a
relatively small sub graph which doesn't
satisfy the property so you get every
pair has been three close to zero one or
just almost all oh yeah I'm cheating but
let's think that it's a date all of them
out or like this important point yeah
domain important points this is a
particularly important point ok ok so
again we are imagining that all pills
are almost almost uniform em so so which
ok there is a very natural graph to
define using this partition it's there
it's what is usually called the cluster
graph ok so I'm replacing every vertex
for every class till I'm picking out I
have a vertex and I have an edge between
ok so if this is VI and this is VJ then
I will have a vertex I and a vertex Jay
and I will have an
between them if the density between them
is closed one and I will have an on edge
between them if the density is close to
zero right this is the natural glove to
define giving this politician okay in
our claim that this graph f that again
has a single vertex from each of the
clusters and it has because the number
of clusters are is polynomial in one
over epsilon then the size of this graph
is also polynomial in one over epsilon I
claim that this graph doesn't satisfy
the semi idea by poverty p ok so wife is
the case i will show you that if he does
satisfy the property then i can modify
the graph relatively few places and get
a graph that satisfies the property
which will be a contradiction right
because we assume that the graph is far
from satisfying the property ok so this
is what we do so assume otherwise so
remember that we assume that the tower
properties semi at your bike it means
that we have these polynomials f1 up to
ft in 2k variables and this boolean
function and we assume that F the glass
that we've just constructed satisfies
this this semi ajiboye property right so
it means that we have x 1 up to exile in
our k such that there is an edge between
two vertices if and only if this
algebraic into this condition is
satisfied ok now what do we do about
with the glove so we do between the
clusters we do the obvious thing right
so if bi and pj I'll a the density
between them is less than Delta we
delete all the edges and if the density
between them is almost 1 then we make it
into a complete bipartite graph right
now what do we do inside the clusters so
what do we do is we say the following
let's take this condition this semi ajab
I'll condition and let's plug into it X
I with itself X I and exile now if this
boolean function returns 1 then I will
turn the developing set into a click and
if it's zero then I will turn it into an
independent set okay so observe that
here i'm making relatively few
modifications because i'm turning an
almost empty bipartite graph
into an empty by paragraph all in almost
complete bipartite graph into a complete
bipartite graph and here I'm making
relatively few modifications because I
can always assume that the number of
clusters is at least one over epsilon so
the number of edges inside the class
turns is small right okay and why so why
does this new glove so remember to
observe that this new glove g prime is a
graph that has our vertex sets each one
of these vertex s is either a click or
an independent set and between two of
these clusters there is either an empty
bipartite graph or complete bipartite
graph right and I claim that this graph
G prime which is close to G satisfies
the semi ojeleye property P ok so why is
this the case how do I prove that the g
prime satisfies the poor the semi ajay
buy property I need to find these
vectors in RK which will witness this
fact right so which which which vectors
will be the witness to this please
effect ok I can just take for every
cluster p I I can take a sign all the
vertices in p.i the same X I ok and
because of this condition together with
this condition we know that I'm that
this the adjusted see relation is is
satisfied by this by these vectors ok so
and this is a contradiction because we
made few modifications when we got a
glove that satisfies the poverty and of
course I'm there is an important step
here which I'm not mentioning is that
how do we show that actually the graph
contains many copies of this f this F is
not of a fixed size right it has the
size that depends on epsilon so we need
to make sure that all the parameters fit
together
and okay so this is all I wanted to say
about the about the positive results so
we just mentioned a few words how much
time do I have 15 minutes m so again so
there our our our necessary condition if
you want our negative result is that a
if if a family is is easily testable
then it must must contain a bipartite
graph in a co bipartite graph and there
as and as I mentioned it's it
generalizes essentially all the all the
put negative previous results save for
one result of Jacob at the Naga and it's
unfortunate we didn't manage to fit into
this framework and so after massaging
this problem a little bit what we end up
with is having to prove the following
lemma is we need to put that for every
non bipartite graph H an epsilon and
positive epsilon this is about your
question before we can construct a graph
that is far from being induced h3 okay
but still it contains relatively few not
only few induced copies of age but any
copy of H induced or not induced okay so
this is this is the key lemma okay so
let me compare this to to to to reside
that will previously known again so what
we need to prove is that for every non
bipartite age I can construct a graph
that is Falcon being induced h3 but
contains very few copies of H induced or
not induced okay so a so noga moved in
pull the same result but without they
induced you you pulled it for every non
bipartite H&F celocita veps alone there
is a graph that is far from being h3 and
contains few copies of H this is the
main part of his office
pure a proof that for non by partek age
the removal emma is held okay and he
asked what happens a what what happens
when instead of looking at the property
of being aged free you look at the
property induced age so notice that our
lemma here it not only implies his
result but it immediately implies also
the result for for the induced h4h
felinez okay so there is there is it the
natural way to prove this result is
doesn't allow you to get this condition
okay but if you remember what I said the
30 minutes ago then we did manage to
solve the problem for being for the
property of being induced age free so
how do we do it we did it by observing
the tits in order to to show that for
essentially every age the removal emma
is hard is by showing that it's enough
to prove this lemma for it for non
bipartite h that contain it triangle
okay and why is this the case because
every glove on at least six vertices we
know that either the graph which
complement contains a triangle and
therefore once you know this you
essentially know this for every non
bipartite graph for any for any graph on
at least six vertices but for our case
it this lemma wasn't enough it was
important to be able to prove this for
every non bipartite age okay so i would
say just a few words about what's going
on there so as in all the negative
results we rely on on parents
construction of values of various
construction so if you've never seen
this what balance construction says is
that you can pick a subset of the first
m integers of size M to the 1 minus
little of one okay that doesn't contain
a non-trivial solution to a three
thermally 22 x plus y equals two zs
meaning doesn't contain a not trivial
three tell mathematic progression okay
now it is well known that the same holds
not only for the three-tail magnetic
population equation but for any equation
s1 to s2 up to sk
k x sk palace 1 and more generally for
any a convex linear equation okay if we
take any any set of coefficient here and
the last coefficient is the sum of the
previous coefficients positive
coefficients okay and i should mention
that these types of equations this is
the these are the only equation for
which we have such a construction of
almost linear size without a non-trivial
solution and as yoshi mentioned in his
talk of course we know that for some
equations there is no way to get such a
construction for some equation there the
correct answer is square root m it's not
it's not em to the 1 minus little o of 1
okay and why do I say this is because in
all of these construction what you end
up with is you want to find to consult a
glove and you want to show that every
copy of the graph e you want to forbid
or you want to show that there are
relatively few copies of it then every
copy of this graph somehow translate
translates into a solution of a linear
equation okay but if you want to be able
to construct a super to get a super
polynomial bound then you need to be
able to extract one of these conditions
okay
and perhaps it's perhaps it could it
could be the case that we could deal
with more general equation but we know
that we couldn't deal with any equation
right if you get the equation X plus y
equals a plus B it will not work because
there is no super polynomial lower bound
for this some constant ok an age of some
constant and you get a linear lower
bound if the sum of the coefficients
don't add up I mean this is the
coefficient here is the sum of these Co
efficient than they're all positive
right but there's other equate like the
when they create what it doesn't have a
I'm Yeah Yeah right but I'm only talking
about homogeneous equations okay trans
yeah yeah okay so this is again so this
is the limit we want to prove that for
every non by palitoy th and positive
epsilon there is a graph that is far
from being induced h3 but contains as I
mentioned this is just a barely super
polynomial lower bound number of copies
induced or not of age ok and ok you know
what it's it's gonna get technical from
this point and I don't have enough time
so I think ok believe me there is there
is stuff going on there ok I think I've
stopped here
[Applause]
plenty of time for questions what was
the original motivation of the
conjecture like what is the original
intuition actuated for the object semi
on the right is the proof is really
different even from what like I mean you
kind of manage to use that polynomial
but it doesn't seem directly coming from
ok ah well you could say when you try to
prove this again as I mentioned this in
passing in the proof is that when you
try to prove this you end up with this
the situation where you want to prove
that that's small that the doctor demo
beautification you you have a small
graph that doesn't satisfy the property
you remember this that I said and it
seems like if you if you look at it it
seems like you should be able to say
that we know that the glove doesn't
satisfy the property I'm not waving my
hands completely right so and you say it
doesn't satisfy the poor but it means
that in this semi Ajay bike relation we
know that there is no way to satisfy
these these constraints so the sudden
Bishop perhaps some you know bisous type
argument or something like that or you
say ok this order is a small number of
small size of the doesn't satisfy the
property and then from this point on you
could you could do stand up things and
and finish up the proof i don't know if
this answer the question about why would
you guess this because you know send me
a job i cover this kind of structured
property so you don't expect to be able
you know to do strange things and come
up with you know with counter examples I
think I know what Nova's intuition was
it already was a regularity lemma for
semi algebraic graphs and hypergraphs of
the polynomial down similar to this so I
think he did you even before that he
thought about it at least that's what I
remember ok but this existed and so he
thought maybe it should be an
application of the polynomial side
their dilemma there you even get the
parts are complete or empty but in terms
of removal it's essentially the same
after you prove your wonderful results
have you have you tried to to check by
the seafoam and single c4 it's hard not
easy it's a we're working on this oh
it's a very nice open problem and it
seems to be isolated it seems to be
isolated yeah but it seems hard it's
kind of at the boundary what does I
conjectural you don't do it I willing to
stay the King Jeff serious oh no oh no
not the conditioner
okay yes well maybe I mean back to my
question which is not a guess but 20
Calvinistic testing I'm just curious
somebody said so you can see that you
can get em to the whatever F to the
epsilon panel beater mini stick testing
by testing all subsets is it interesting
and that somebody said can you do a
polynomial and Ellen one web so much oh
is it known and I'm just curious
somebody said that maybe you can do
polynomial in n + 1 over epsilon no
because they cool right okay so you can
use all I mean if you could do it for
capability then you could solve
technical Shortcake or ability in
polynomial time no this is absolutely
you're saying let's just take epsilon to
be 1 over n square always it can you get
some function of epsilon which is depend
on the bounce I was just kind of cured
because it's qualitatively seems kind of
interesting and also mighty one of the
cases where the humanistic and
randomized channel seem to date as fast
but I don't know you can look at this
over the knowledge is so you can you
almost can I we shall ever have to be so
small but it's only depends on the size
of the set
there has to be exponentially smaller
sizes but size isn't setting upon take
it offline yeah all right so let's take
this up
[Applause]